et on avait besoin aussi je pense que
c'est intéressant d'avoir une vision qui
sorte un peu du spectre
franco-français donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle on est très heureuse de
vous accueillir j'ai dis très heureuse
puisque nous sommes toutes les trois
donc rapporteurs de cette mission d'une
façon transpartisane comme on a
l'habitude souvent de travailler ici au
Sénat et au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques donc vien arti
galas qui est sénatrice des Hautes
Pyrénées pour le groupe socialiste Amel
gaker qui est sénatrice du calé pour le
groupe des centristes et moi-même
sénatrice des Alpes Maritimes pour le
groupe les républicains voilà donc la
composition que vous avez devant vous
donc monsieur Boris cournet vous êtes
chef par intérim de la division de
l'économie publique à l'Organisation de
coopération et de développement
économique l'OCDE donc les questions du
logement et je le disais sont bien
souvent abordé avec un prisme qui est
stricto
franco-fançais car chaque pays bien bien
évidemment à son histoire et aussi ses
spécificités sur le sujet pour autant il
y a je pense au moins deux raisons qui
doivent nous amener en l'espèce à une
démarche plus ouverte le choc que
constitue la hausse brutale des taux
d'intérêt sur les marchés immobiliers
est un choc mondial on peut même penser
qu'il est d'une ampleur beaucoup plus
importante dans les pays où à la
différence de la France les ménages
empruntent à taux variable puisque nous
avons cette spécificité de prêt à taux
fixes de plus même si on l'aurait
presque oublié le covid a constitué un
autre choc commun à tous les pays en
matière de logement la crise actuelle le
masque quelque peu mais le covid impacte
durablement l'offre et la demande de
logement au-delà les comparaisons
internationales sont essentielles à la
compréhension et à la résolution de la
crise car depuis 2017 le président de la
République s'appuie sur quelques
éléments comparatifs ou de théorie
économique qu' pour justifier les coupe
qu'ilopère dans le budget du logement ou
dans les outils d'aide à
l'investissement locatif ou encore
d'aide à l'accession à la propriété ces
données sont donc un élément central du
débat de l'analyse de la crise et des
solution à mettre en œuvre son c'est
dire tout l'intérêt que l'on va porter
aux éléments que vous allez pouvoir nous
présenter dans votre introduction avec
le temps de parole que vous souhaiterez
donc prendre et ensuite bien évidemment
nous serons amenés à vous poser quelques
questions donc je précise également que
cette audition fait l'objet d'une
retransmission en direct en vidéo sur le
site internet et sur les réseaux sociaux
du Sénat voilà je vous laisse la parole
bien volontiers je vous vous remercie
beaucoup madame la la présidente madame
les les sénatrices monsieurs je suis
très heureux d'être présent ici pour
partager les conclusions des travaux que
nous avons mené à l' CDE depuis
longtemps et qui peuvent fournir des
éléments de comparaison internationale
sur la situation française et qui me
semble
particulièrement utile dans la mesure où
beaucoup des questions que rencontrent
la France sont communes avec de nombreux
autres pays de l'OCDE très souvent et
nous allons le voir dans les différents
graphiques la France se trouve proche du
du groupe des pays typiques de l'OCDE il
y a quelques exceptions et notamment
vous mentionnez les les dépens de
logement la France fait partie des pays
qui ont les dépenses publiques parmi les
plus élevés en pourcentage du PIB pour
ce secteur mais souvent la la France est
vraiment un pays
caractéristique de ce qui se passe dans
euh euh beaucoup de membres de l'OCDE
alors je me permets de poser une
question pour savoir comment faire
passer eu je vous fais signe très bien
et donc on va passer voilà au au au
suivant pour préciser le cadre dans
lequel nous avons mené ces travaux bon
le logement c'est entre 20 et 30 % de la
consommation des ménages c'est un
secteur donc central de l'activité
économique c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles l'économie fonctionne donc à
ce titre bien évidemment l'OCDE depuis
qu'elle existe suit le secteur du
logement cela étant dit depuis 2019 a
été lancé une initiative spéciale visant
à ce que tous les premièrement renforcer
ses travaux et deuxièmement mener de
manière très étroite des travaux dans
tous les domaines que touchent le
logement qui sont très nombreux puisque
bon c'est un secteur économique
important personnellement je travaille à
comme vous le mentionnez à la direction
des affaires économiques de l'OCDE mais
c'est aussi bien évidemment un secteur
décisif pour l'inclusion sociale pour le
fonctionnement du marché du travail et
les impacts environnementaux sont
considérables aussi et à ce ce titre il
nous a semblé judicieux en 2018 donc le
programme m'a été lancé à proprement
parler ensuite en 2019 de mener des
études concertées pour regarder les
enjeux du secteur du logement aussi bien
environnementaux sociaux qu'économiques
dans un cadre intégré et aussi
considérer en même temps toutes les
politiques publiques qui influencent le
secteur parce que là aussi elles sont
nombreuses et très souvent elles ont des
interactions il a des politiques qui
n'ont rien disons d'efficace ou
d'ineefficace en tant que tel mais et
qui peuvent poser problème en
conjonction avec d'autres peut-être pour
donner un exemple pour illustrer cela si
un gouvernement ou même des des États
fédérés parce que dans un certain nombre
de pays de l'OCDE ce sont les par
exemple au Canada c'est le niveau
vraiment des des provinces qui a la le
pouvoir le plus important en matière de
logement si une autorité publique mène
des politiques qui encouragent les
propriétaires occupants qui encourage le
fait d'être propriétaire de son logement
plutôt que locataire cela avec des des
avantages pour ce secteur là bon ça peut
poser des difficultés sont souvent des
politiques coûteuses mais en la
situation va être très différente
suivant qu'on a ou non des coûts de
transaction importants sur la vente des
logements et en particulier des taxes
importantes sur la V des logement si on
encourage les personnes à être
propriétaires de leur logement mais
qu'en même temps les transactions ne
sont pas taxées
ça va poser un nombre limité de
problèmes si en même temps les
transactions sont taxées à un niveau
élevé comme c'est le cas en France par
exemple là on va créer des blocage sur
la mobilité géographique et par
conséquent des obstacles au bon
fonctionnement du du marché du travail
parce qu'on crée un obstacle à franchir
pour accepter un nouveau travail lorsque
celui-ci se trouve dans une autre zone
géographique un obstacle considérable
quand on a des des taxes qui sont de
l'ordre de 6 à 8 % du du prix d'
logement c'est vraiment une et qui est
très élevé à franchir donc on va pas le
faire pour par exemple un nouveau
travail qui peut-être plus intéressant
peut-être plus rémunérateur mais aussi
risqué et qui demande un déménagement
donc c'est pour illustrer l'importance
de prendre en compte ces interactions il
y en a vraiment beaucoup et donc on peut
suivre euh avec la la la diapositive
suivante pour voilà entrer dans le vif
du sujet de situer la France ici euh
quand on regarde je venais de parler des
propriétaires occupants la part de
propriétaires occupants ici ils sont
scindés entre ceux qui ont ton corps un
emprunt en cours en bleu clair et ceux
qui ont soit ont acheté sans emprunt
enfin c'est assez rare mais plutôt ont
fini de rembourser leur emprunt c'est le
bleu foncé on voit que la France bon a
une majorité de propriétaires occupants
mais en même temps aussi un secteur
locatif plus développé que beaucoup
d'autres pays de l'OCDE avec à
l'intérieur de ce secteur locatif une
part importante du parc social il y a
une petite remarque à faire ici c'est
que si on va pas le faire maintenant
parce que voilà le sujet est vaste mais
certaines des comparaisons entre les
parcs sociaux sont compliquées parce que
pour certains pays le partage n'est pas
disponible et donc pour certains pays
qui disposent d'un parc social il est
intégré à ce qui est appelé ici sur ce
graphique marché privé donc voilà si on
veut se pencher plus précisément sur sur
ce graphique il faut avoir cette cette
réserve en tête on peuté par locataire
total ah c'était
pour ah oui effectivement bon là il y a
un petit problème de de graphique ça
devrait être là oui il y a un petit
problème de en réalité ce sont
[Musique]
les voilà oui pardon c'est exactement ça
c'està-dire c'est quand on n'est pas
capable de partager de faire le partage
entre locataire privé et locataire
social on a créé cette catégorie
locataire
total parce que oui
le le secteur sociale est est défini
d'une manière générale que ce sont les
les logements locatifs qui sont offerts
à un prix inférieur à celui du marché
mais ensuite on a vraiment des modalités
de fourniture très différentes et je
reviendrai un petit peu plus tard pour
faire écho oui à ce que vous soulignez
oui la France et là vraiment c'est c'est
très net se distingue par la part très
réduite des prê on les appel
hypothécaires ici en réalité ce sont les
prêts au logement dans
leur semble donc vraiment la plupart
sont à tofix bon dans les pays grands
pays de l'OCDE on a aussi les les
États-Unis qui ont une part très
importante de taux fixe donc ça a cet
effet que les emprunteurs existants sont
protégés des effets de la hausse des
taux mais bien évidemment les nouveaux
acquéreurs ne le sont pas les promoteurs
ne le sont pas donc on a bien sûr un
effet de la hausse des taux sur le
marché immobilier aussi donc si on suit
avec le graphique suivant ici pour
illustrer bon l'ampleur de la hausse des
prix du logement qui est AJ de
l'inflation des prix à la consommation
ici on voit qu'elle a été c'est le bleu
foncé elle a été très forte partout dans
l' CDE depuis le début des années 90
et vraiment spécialement forte en
France je ne vais pas m'apesantir sur ce
constat qui est bien bien connu et
passer au à la diapositive suivante pour
tout de suite faire une remarque sur le
fait que bien sûr quand on parle du
marché du logement en général c'est une
forme ou de d'AB rviation puisqueil y a
à peu près autant de marchés qu'il y a
de de zones de vie et une dimension dans
laquelle le marché est réellement
national c'est sa dimension financière
où là il est vraiment intégré à
l'échelle nationale moins à l'échelle
européenne pour l'instant avec bon des
différences considérables aussi bien en
niveau
voilà on voit
cette cette carte qui illustre les
différences au passage je salue les
efforts oui on peut voir passer à la
suivante c'est c'est parfait qui montre
que on a aussi beaucoup de différences
pour l'évolution ici dans la période
qu'on peut tracer grâce à cette base de
données que je salue de déclaration des
valeurs foncières à la France est
vraiment euh un pays euh on peut dire
pilote on peut dire modèle dans le
partage des données sur les transactions
immobilières d'ailleurs c'est cette base
de données qui euh qui partage à
l'intégralité des des transactions avec
les prix les mètres carrés nous a amené
à faire des études dont je replerai un
petit peu plus tard sur donc la France
et 15 autres pays de l'OCDE pour
lesquels nous avons pu trouver des
données comparables en réalité souvent
moins détaillées que que Cell de la
France ce qu'on voit ici bon c'est la la
cartographie des des changements qui là
aussi est très hétérogène donc si on
revient voilà on va revenir à
l'international avec oui je vous en PR
question pourquoi grand
test euh je suis pas en mesure de voir
oui qu'estce qui fait qu'on a pas des
données
euh non je suis pas en mesure de
répondre sur parce que la chose que je
peux dire d'ailleurs c'est qu'il y a des
il y a des blancs aussi he il y a des
des creux l'endroits où il y a des
blancs c'est parce qu'on a pas assez de
quand c'est ailleurs que le grand test
euh alors il des endroits où c'est
ailleurs que le grand test on a des
blancs c'est quand on a pas assez de
données pour pouvoir calculer la
variation de manière si on a que
quelques transactions voilà on calcule
pas la variation parce que c'est trop
hasardeux en revanche le C c'est une
autre explication cela dit
euh des blancs comme ça bon
effectivement c'est un blanc là dans la
carte de France mais je veux dire que en
comparaison de des données qu'on a sur
beaucoup de pays ça reste déjà quelque
chose de de qualité c'est c'est souvent
difficile d'avoir ce ce type de données
et en France ce qui est remarquable
c'est qu'elles sont aussi offertes en
accès libre donc si on passe au voilà
ici pour dire que nous ce que
on
revient à la fois à l'échelle nationale
et régionale on à l'échelle nationale on
a des données très longues on peut
remonter sur plusieurs décennies
jusqu'aux années début des années 80
pour beaucoup de pays à l'échelle
régionale un petit peu moins mais on a
beauccoup de régions aussi et ce que
nous avons regardé c'est quels sont les
déterminants des prix du logement à long
terme
euh vous évoquiez tout à l'heure les les
taux d'intérêt qui sont un déterminant
très très important à des variations à
moyen terme que se passe-t-il quand on
regarde ce qui s'est passé au cours des
30 dernières années cette considérable
envolé des des prix du logement partout
et quels sont les les facteurs communs
alors
d'abord en dehors du marché du du
logement la la démographie bon c'est
c'est c'est c'est évident puisque
évidemment c'est le plus on a de
population plus on a besoin de logement
pour pour que chacun ait un toit mais
c'est aussi économiquement très
important impact vraiment sur les prix
du logement est considérable et donc
quand on voit
que quand on regarde par exemple les
tendances du logement en Allemagne ou au
Japon qui depuis plusieurs décennies ont
une démographie faible bon on a des prix
du logement qui sont très à tonne
et avec des exceptions qui apparaissent
notamment en Allemagne lorsqu'on a eu
les les mouvements d'immigration à
partir de 2015 c'est à ce moment-là
qu'on a vu de reprise des des prix du
logement donc c'est vraiment un un
facteur fondamental le revenu des
ménages aussi lorsque au-delà de la
démographie le revenu augmente on a
automatiquement une volonté de de
l'utiliser pour avoir de meilleures
conditions de logement et ça se voit
dans les prix et ensuite de manière
déterminante et c'est vraiment de façon
il y a un ordre dans dans ces facteurs
ici le manque de terrain alors qu'il
peut être un manque de terrain
géographique quand on regarde des
métropoles comme San Francisco par
exemple on voit l'effet du manque de
terrain mais pour rester sur ce même
exemple de San Francisco on a aussi un
effet déterminant des politiques
d'occupation des sol en l'occurrence à
San Francisco es sont très restrictives
et ça se traduit par des des fortes
hausses des prix une faible activité de
construction on voit aussi que sur
longue période les les politiques
d'encadrement des loyers au-delà
des des phénomènes qu'elles ont à à à
plus brève échéance du fait de
d'entraîner un retrait d'une partie des
logements sur le marché on en effet même
sur l'offre globale de logement parce
que on a moins de construction de
logement àouer et donc on a un effet de
l'encadrement des loyers lorsqu'il est
strict lorsque cet effet nous
l'observons lorsqu'on a des dispositifs
qui vraiment mettent un plafond au
niveau des loyers comme par exemple ceux
qui
sont mis en œuvre dans certaines grandes
villes en France depuis plusieurs années
il s'agit pas des de cement des loyers
pour les locataires en cours de location
euh notamment les les beaucoup de pays
ont des dispositifs d'indexation pour
empêcher les augmentations de loyers
arbitrairees à l'intérieur d'un contrat
ou pour un même locataire et ce ce type
de réglementation n'a n'introduit pardon
n'implique pas ce type d'effet ensuite
lorsqu'on regarde les prix on voit aussi
que les les réductions fiscales et ici
notamment ce qui est présente dans
beaucoup de pays et qui a un effet sur
ce résultat ce sont les exonérations euh
de d'impôts qui sont liés aux intérêts
d'emprunt beaucoup de pays ont mis en
œuvre ou mettre en œuvre ce dispositif
bon il y en a eu dans l'histoire de la
fiscalité française il y a eu ce ce type
de dispositif à plusieurs reprises il
est encore très important aux États-Unis
par exemple il a été très important au
Pays-Bas il est en voie de réduction
actuellement avec une réforme qui qui
est étalée sur une longue période ce qui
est d'ailleurs ce que nous recommandons
pour ce type de réforme qui ne peut
avoir lieu que sur longue période sinon
les effets sont vraiment abruptes sur le
marché du du logement si on enlève ce
type d'avantage très rapidement et oui
je vous en
prieéc le oui c'est simplement en fait
c'est un mécanisme de lorsqu'on a des
des disposit par exemple si on pense oui
au
dispositif hollandais avant la réforme
qui a commencé dans les années 2010 où
le dispositif qui est au qui est présent
au aux États-Unis où lorsqu'on emprunte
on réduit ses impôts à fonction en
fonction des des intérêts qu'on paye sur
l'emprunt lorsqu'on a ce type d'avantage
et que l'offre la possibilité de
construire est réduite comme c'est le
cas
dans bon nombre de zones urbaines des
des des Pays-Bas où il y a à la fois des
questions géographiques et aussi une
politique d'urbanisme stri et aux
États-Unis c'est plus compliqué parce
qu'on a vraiment des effets très
disparates entre des des zones où il est
très facile de construire où là on a
moins d'effet sur les prix mais dans les
dans les zones où il est difficile de
construire ce type de mesure de
solvabilisation des achats financés par
l'emprunt ou
entraîne une augmentation des emprunts
plus et donc c'est
çaou on a finalement un phénomène si le
on a une forme de rationnement de de
l'offre quand on solvabilise la demande
on va Infiné retrouver à peu près les
mêmes acheteurs expost que ceux qu'on
aurait eu avant mais avec plus
d'endettement et des des pris plus élevé
et donc on a un dispositif fiscal qui
qui est onéreux et qui aura
principalement bénéficié à ceux qui
étaient propriétaires des terrain ou des
biens immobiliers avant sa avant sa mise
en œuvre donc si on
puis le avec la diapositive
suivante je voulais voilà ça c'était
juste pour rappeler on peut passer
rapidement sur cette diapositive veut
dire que la hausse importante des prix
d' immobiliers en France à la différence
de beaucoup d'autres pays qu'on peut
voir ici ne peut être attribué
principalement à la démographie ou à la
croissance du revenu par tête
puisque en comparaison des pays de
l'OCDE la démographie de la France n'est
pas spécialement viigoureuse bon je vais
pas revenir sur ce ce sujet qui a fait
beaucoup l'objet de débat récemment et
la croissance du PIB par tête
et relativement relativement faible
aussi sur quand on la regarde sur longue
période ici depuis 1990 donc ça veut
dire que c'est de côté des des autres
facteurs notamment des politiques
d'occupation des sols des politiques
d'urbanisme qu'il faut aller chercher
les causes de la hausse tendantielle des
prix du logement en France donc on peut
passer à la suite s'il vous merci
beaucoup euh donc on a en effectivement
une construction de logement en
pourcentage du parc total de logement
qui bon
est un peu inférieure à la moyenne on
voit que la France vraiment dans ce
groupe qui est assez de dans ce groupe
de pays qui est qui
est qui est ici en dessous de la moyenne
mais pas beaucoup en dessous et on voit
que la la situation est comparable à
celle de beaucoup de pays notamment
européens donc si on
poursuit oui c'est un peu oui on
a effective oui alors c'est pas
effectivement c'est 2020 c'est pas
sensible à la covid he effectivement
l'indicateur parce que c'est 2020 ou
dernière année disponible lorsqu'il y
avait des problèmes de données liées à
la covid on a pris 2019 dans ce dans ce
graphique ici c'est une mesure
synthétique qui
regarde le pourcentage d'augmentation de
la de construction de logement lorsque
lesix pr augmente de 1 % de combien de
de quelle quantité
la construction de logement va-t-elle
augmenter et en général on considère que
le marché est raisonnablement équilibré
lorsqu'on se situe au voisinage de 1
c'estàdun augmentation de 1 % des prix
entraîne une augmentation de l'offre à
terme d'environ 1 % et on voit que la
France fait partie des pays où l'offre
réagit difficilement aux variations de
de prix donc c'est une autre manière de
voir une autre manière de voir euh
pourquoi la les prix ont augmenté autant
au cours des dernières décennies on peut
passer à la suite ce qui est important
c'est que cette euh hausse des prix de
l'immobilier c'est pas seulement une
question d'actif c'est aussi une
question de consommation c'estàd que
dans la consommation des ménages à cause
de la chaireté du logement
on a ici dans les depuis 2000 dans les
20 dernières années plusieurs points de
pourcentage de la consommation
supplémentaires qui ont été absorbé par
le logement on voit que c'est pas du
tout spécifique à la France comme bon on
en parlait au début la France est assez
typique d'autres pays de l'OCDE et on
voit aussi que la que le logement est
une partie très importante de la
consommation on est proche de de 30
%. ici quand on voit ce que ce la donne
en terme d'accès de qualité au logement
pour l'un des indicateurs il sont assez
peu nombreux les indicateurs de qualité
qu'on peut comparer entre pays ici c'est
celui du surpeuplement donc le sur un
logement surpeuplé bon c'est une
définition assez compliquée pour tenir
compte des différentes situations mais
par
exemple si lorsque dans un logement de
dans une famille deux enfants
adolescents de sexe opposé doivent
dormir dans la même chambre on considère
que le logement est
surpeuplé évidemment si les parents et
des enfants doivent dormir dans la même
chambre on considère que le logement est
surpeuplé enfin voilà une définition
assez compliquée si j'avais mis la note
de bas de page Jeuris en problème sur le
graphique parce que il faut tenir compte
de des différentes situations on voit
que la France voilà est vraiment dans la
la moyenne de l'OCDE c'est le le pays
le des plus
proches de la de la moyenne et avec des
écarts qui sont pas si qui sont
relativement resserrés entre les
différentes catégories de revenus et ça
c'est lié aux politiques social en
particulier au parc social de logement
en France donc on passe à la à la
suivante euh regarder la pauvreté
énergétique là aussi la France est
vraiment proche de la moyenne de l'OCDE
avec bien sûr là une différence qui est
importante entre les 20 % de de ménages
ayant les revenus les plus faibles et
les les ménages
ça c'est puisque la question qu'on pose
c'est est-ce que vous avez une
difficulté à chauffer votre
logement donc si on poursuit
oui pour placer parce que sur la la
question du logement des des jeunes on a
aussi quelques éléments sur l'accès des
jeunes au logement alors ça bon c'est un
graphique qui mélange bien
sûr la situation du secteur du logement
et aussi des éléments qui peuvent
relever de de normes ou de préférences
culturelles mais néanmoins ce qu'on voit
c'est que sur le nombre le pourcentage
des jeunes qui habitent
en avec leurs parents la France là aussi
et vraiment dans la dans la moyenne de
l'OCDE ce qui sera intéressant c'est de
suivre cet indicateur au fil du temps là
malheureusement on peut pas le comparer
euh parce qu'il serait intéressant de
voir quelle était la situation en 2000
et et dans quel sens on a changé donc si
on poursuit pour parler des des
politiques sociales voilà le logement
social qui euh euh explique en partie
pourquoi les effets de la hausse
générale des prix non euh sont
compatible avec le fait qu'on n pas un
surpeuplement exceptionnel par rapport à
la moyenne de de l'OCDE c'est qu'on a le
parc social est particulièrement
développé en
France par rapport à à beaucoup
d'autres beaucoup d'autres pays de
l'OCDE et en notant que effectivement
beaucoup de pays de l'OCDE ont des parcs
sociaux vraiment très étroit comme
vous pouvez le le voir
ici alors on peut suivre voilà ce alors
la suite du parc social c'est la la
barre rouge les dépenses alors son bleus
pour tous les autres pays j'ai mis la la
France en rouge les dépenses publiques
d'investissement dans le logement en
fait bon ici c'est toutes les dépenses
publiques d'investissement dans le
logement et les équipement collectif ce
qui est une mesure beaucoup plus large
que le parc social parce que en fait on
a très peu de on peut comparer les
dépenses pour le parc social seulement
entre quatre ou 5 pays de l' CDE donc ça
c'est peu informatif on a de meilleurs
éléments comparatifs sur les allocations
logement qu'on voit ici avec le triangle
on voit que la France est aussi un pays
où les allocations logement sont un
poste de dépenses
important donc si on on poursuit et ce
que je voulais montrer ici c'est que
dans on a eu une tendance dans
les la la décennie passée dans beaucoup
de de pays de l'OCDE
à réduire justement les dépenses de
construction les dépenses publiques de
construction de logement alors que les
allocations ont été aide à la personne
aide à la pierre aide à la personne aide
à la pierre exactement et
euh je vais revenir d'illeurs sur un
autre j'ai quelques voilà quelques
éléments alors celui-là je laisse
peut-être je vais pas le commenter en
détail parce que il serait trop long il
est plus ici pour référence mais pour
euh souligner que oui be on voit que les
nombres de pays sont élevés ici dans sur
ce cette diapositive par rapport aux 38
pays de de l'OCDE donc le logement c'est
un domaine dans lequel les gouvernements
sont actifs aussi bien sur l'offre que
sur la demande on a beaucoup de
dispositifs d'aide de logement même si
comme on l'a vu sur le diapositive pr la
diapositive précédente il sont pas
toujours il sont souvent d'ampleur
beaucoup plus réduite que la France on a
beaucoup de
dispositifs sur l'offre et aussi bien
des dispositifs financiers que des
dispositifs de régulation je voudrais
passer un petit peu plus de temps sur la
diapositive suivante pour dire quels
sont nous à l'OCDE les éléments que nous
avons rassemblés sur l'efficacité des
différentes modalité
d'intervention lorsqu'on regarde les
dispositifs sur la demande alors ne
voyez pas si curieux il y a un petit bug
graphique là le décalage de demande
c'est pas une volonté de faire passer un
message c'est juste un bug
d'affichage
le ce qu'on voit c'est que les
dispositifs de demande ici sont pour les
allocations de différents ordre donc la
dépense publique mais on a les mêmes
effets que ceux qu'on observe pour les
réductions d'impôts ou les dépenses
fiscales et finalement c'est assez
logique c'est que lorsqu'on a ce type
d'intervention et que l'offre est rigide
on a un petit peu plus parfois très
peu ou un petit peu plus de construction
et beaucoup d'augmentation de prix et
donc on a beaucoup de la dépense qui est
liée à ce type d'intervention qui est
perdue enfin disons SAU pour les
propriétaires mais qui est perdu dans la
hausse des loyers donc on voit ça
au États-Unis ù des études ont été
faites à ce sujet il y en a eu plusieurs
de de grandes qualités quit ont été mené
en en France en regardant les les APL et
également en Finlande et finalement avec
alors que ces dispositifs sont quand
même très différents c'est très local
c'est jamais structuré tout à fait de la
même façon mais on a toujours des des
estimations qui donnent des résultats
assez forts quand on regarde de l'autre
côté des interventions sur l'offre la
différence qu'on a du côté de l'offre
c'est que même enfin des deux côtés on
peut avoir des problèmes mais du côté de
l'offre même si on s'y prend mal on
finit quand même par construire des
logements et donc on va quand même avoir
un effet sur le volume de logement alors
ils sonont peut-être pas de bonne
qualité ils seront peut-être pas au bon
endroit et c'est important de de de
d'avoir ces considérations en tête mais
au moins on a un effet sur l'offre donc
on a tendance pour la même dépense
publique à avoir des effets plus sûrs
euh du lorsqu'on intervient sur l'offre
ensuite on a des dispositifs très
différents alors il en a beaucoup plus
que ceux qui sont là mais ceux qui sont
mis en avant ici ils le sont en en tout
cas ceux de l'Autriche et du Danemarc
parce qu'ils ont fait leur preuve celui
de la Léonie il est en train d'être mis
en œuvre donc c'est trop tôt pour avoir
un avis mais c'est pour signaler que
cela évolue en Autriche on a un
dispositif qui est très intéressant
notamment pour le logement intermédiaire
pour il est intéressant aussi pour le
logement social
mais me St pas très utille d'en parler
beaucoup ici parce qu'il est très
comparable à la France il est fait par
les municipalités il ressemble beaucoup
à ce que ce qui ce qui se fait en France
mais pour le
secteur intermédiaire les ménages qui
ont des revenus plus élevés que ceux qui
vont dans des logements strictement
sociaux mais qui ont aussi des
difficultés d'accès au logement
l'Autriche a un secteur très développé
d'entreprises immobilières à but non
lucratif qui bénéficient d'un statut
fiscal adapté qui ont aussi des
dispositif d'accès au crédit spécifique
et qui ont l'obligation de réinvestir
l'intégralité de leur profit dans
l'entretien ou la construction de
logement alors c'est un dispositif qui
s'est mis en place sur une très longue
période en Autriche mais qui continue de
de fonctionner très bien euh et
notamment pour c'est ça l'accès des des
classes moyennes des moyennes enfin
disons ça c'est toujours un
conceptuellement un concept difficile à
définir disons plutôt les les revenus
entre 20 et 50 % de de la distribution
des des des 20 et 50 % de ménages qui
sont dans la distribution des revenus
qui sont typiquement au-delà du cœur de
cible du logement social mais une partie
de la population où l'accès au logement
est souvent difficile le Danemark a un
système qui infin a des effets
comparable même s'il est plus il est
structuré différemment plus centralisé
avec un fond qui centralise justement
ces profits ces profits qui sont régulés
qui sont limités mais qui existent sur
ces les logements intermédiaires les
profits sont centralisés et ensuite ils
sont redistribués pour l'entretien lourd
et la construction de nouveaux logements
sociaux et c'est un dispositif de ce
type que la la est en train de mettre en
œuvre et avec une une intervention de
Conseil de l'OCDE on peut passer au ah
pardon non oui on pourrait je ou j'ai
mis le lien pour le ce ce rapport sur la
Lettonie donc si on alors il y a
beaucoup on va pouvoir pas laisser plus
vite parce qu'il y a des points dont
j'ai déjà parlé je vais je vais pas me
répéter voilà sur l'encadrement des
loyers j'ai parlé des effets qu' celui
de la la France est plutôt dans la
moyenne haute de l'OCDE en sachant que
là c'est y en a indicateur composite qui
est euh
euh qui date de 2019 en est il est en
cours de mise à jour et depuis on a eu
plutôt en France un mouvement de
resserrement de l'encadrement des loyers
et le degré de protection des locataires
notamment
la la nature des des procédures de
euh d'expulsion euh et la la protection
des locataires qui sont en place est
particulièrement développé en en France
ce qu'on observe sur la protection des
loocataire c'est un effet qui est
comparable à celui dont je parlais
auparavant pour
les la taxation des transaction qui est
le fait que on a moins de beaucoup moins
de mobilité résidentielle lorsqu'on a un
degré de protection des locataires
élevés en ce qui est logique une fois
qu'on bénéficie de cette protection on
réfléchit avant de de de et ça peut
créer des ou notamment si on a on a on
sait bien que lorsqu'on est locataire et
si on se retrouve dans une situation de
revenu qui Devi bien incertain ben il il
va devenir très difficile de louer un
nouveau logement donc on a ce genre de
d'obstacle à la mobilité géographique
qui accompagne la protection des
locataires et qu'on observe de manière
systématique c'est-à-dire que on a des
résultats quantitatifs sur ce sujet
lorsqu'on compare les les différents
pays de l'OCDE donc si on passe au à la
diapositive suivante voilà ce qui est
notable en France c'est le
l'éclatement la fragmentation
du pouvoir foncier les décisions d'usage
des sols les décisions de densification
de l'espace urbain sont prises à un
niveau extrêmement décentralisé on a en
France autant de municipalités quasiment
que qu'X États-Unis quand on voit ici
sur sur ce grand rectangle l'ensemble
des municipalités de l'OCDE on voit que
par rapport à la taille de la France
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de l'OCDE la
France en concentre vraiment beaucoup et
or c'est la municipalité qui a le infin
le pouvoir urbain décisif et ce qu'on
observe et là aussi de de manière
quantitative lorsqu'on compare les
différents pays c'est que plus le
pouvoir de décision
est
fragmentaire plus euh justement on a une
rigidité de de l'offre plus l'offre est
rigide et ce qu'on explique par le fait
que ça euh donne la possibilité au
propriétaire en place notamment aux
voisins des zones où il peut y avoir la
construction il ils ont avec des
municipalités de petite taille ils ont
beaucoup plus de possibilité de
s'opposer aux nouvelles constructions et
cela freine la
construction et on a le même phénomène
lorsque on a mais moins fort toutefois
quantitativement le même phénomène
lorsqu'on a une superposition de de
pouvoir c'est plusieurs échelons
administratifs peuvent faire obstacle
bon mécaniquement c'est plus difficile
de de construire mais ce qui est quand
même plus déterminant c'est cette c'est
cette fragmentation et à l'inverse
lorsque le pouvoir foncier se trouve euh
au niveau de la métropole vraiment de la
zone de vie et d'activité économique à
ce moment-là on a en général plus de de
dynamisme euh de la construction enfin
dynamisme pas dans le sens construire
pour construire hein dans le sens réagir
à la demande lorsqu'il y a de lorsqu'il
y a de la
demande voilà ici bon j'ai pas c'est un
peu pour mémoire parce que ce fait est
bien connu mais le fait que le bon la
fiscalité d'une manière générale est
élevée en France en comparaison des pays
de l'OCDE lorsqu'on prend l'ensemble de
la fiscalité elle est la plus élevée de
tous les pays de l'OCDE et lorsqu'on
regarde le logement c'est à peu près
c'est à peu près la même chose
euh et cela dit comme j'en parlais
auparavant on a des des propriétés très
différentes de la fiscalité du logement
d'une façon générale le logement est
plutôt un bon support fiscal c'est le
support fiscal le moins mobile donc
c'est un bon point d'appui pour la
fiscalité en revanche les taxes qui
portent sur les transactions comme les
en France les droits de mutation ont
beaucoup plus
d'effets économiques adverses même
sociaux quand on pense aux effets sur le
marché du travail les obstacles à la
mobilité professionnel que les taxes qui
sont payées chaque année comme bon
l'ancienne taxe d'habitation ou la taxe
foncière si
on poursuit oui vous mentionniez tout à
l'heure madame la Présidente les la
covid et alors avec la covid on a alors
on a un effet d'ensemble qui est le fait
que en passant avec le télétravail on a
eu une peut-être simplement le fait de
passer plus de temps à la maison mais
au-delà le le télétravail une volonté de
d'avoir de meilleures conditions de
logement sans doute une volonté pour
beaucoup de s'agrandir pour avoir un
bureau tout simplement donc on a un
effet général mais on a aussi un effet
géographique voilà en ofFrance si bon en
réalité en dehors des États-Unis on a
assez peu d'exemples quantitativement
importants
de secteur du marché du travail qui
devientent du télétravail à 100 % qui
permet d'aller très loin des villes en
revanche ce qui est très développé dans
beaucoup de de pays de l'OCDE c'est le
fait de pouvoir télétravailler un 2 ou 3
jours par semaine et ça change
l'équation du choix de de logement on
peut habiter
euh plus loin parce que bon on va mieux
tolérer on va mieux tolérer un temps
plus important dans les transports et on
voit ça on voit ça quand on regarde les
prix du logement c'est là je disa on a
donc fait ce travail inspiré comme je
disais au départ par le les données
fournies par la France on s'est dit
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on peut trouver
les mêmes données pour d'autres pays on
les a trouvé pour 15 autres pays donc on
arrive à couvrir on couvre en fait
beaucoup plus de villes que ça mais on a
8845 euh métropole pour lesquel on peut
faire
ce calcul qui est celui de la de
comparer le prix du logement au prix
moyen dans la métropole en fonction de
la distance au centre donc bien
évidemment il décroit au fur et à mesure
qu'on s'éloigne du centre si on le
regarde en 201
oui c'est ça en 2017 c'est le trait
pointiller entre 2017 et 2019 ilue de se
passer le phénomène qui se produit
depuis des décennies qui est le fait que
les centres devenaient de plus en plus
chers et les
les
banlieux moins cher même si c'est pas un
phénomène uniforme c'était pas le cas
partout en particulier aux États-Unis si
on remontait plus dans le passé mais
avec la covid c'est produit en
renversement on a eu moins de pression
sur les centres donc on a eu ce c'est la
voilà la ligne verte qui est là
nettement en dessous de la en dessous de
la rouge et un petit peu plus de
pression sur les périphéries et on on
peut faire des travaux plus détaillés
que ça en fait on a croisé ces données
de prix avec des observations
satellitees que nous avons traité avec
des outils d'intelligence artificielle
pour avoir une estimation de l'activité
de construction et on voit que dans les
zones où il y a eu plus d'activités de
construction on n pas cet effet de
d'augmentation des des prix donc on a eu
un un report vers les périphéries qui a
été voilà qui a eu plus ou moins
d'effets sur les prix suivant que la
construction pouvait réagir ou non on a
d'ailleurs manière de lier cet effet à
CIT
à effectivement au télétravail parce
qu'on voit que dans les métropoles où on
a vraiment une bonne qualité homogène de
l'accès Internet cet effet est plus
présent que dans les zones où la qualité
de l'accès à Internet se
dégrade lorsqu'on s'approche des des
zones plus rurales ici donc c'est pour
montrer que Paris ne fait pas
d'exception bon à gauche c'est le niveau
là vraiment il y a pas de surprise c'est
beaucoup plus ch bon beaucoup plus cher
au centre et à l'ouest que dans la
périphérie ce qui est plus intéressant
c'est le de voir à droite le changement
2019-2021 où on voit que et bien le euh
le centre c'est on est proche du blanc
les augmentations les variations au
centre ont été moins fortes et on a eu
des zones dans les périphéries avec des
des variations plus
fortes donc c'est ce voilà de les
éléments tirés principalement de ces
deux publications dont je voulais parler
aujourd'hui puis je suis à à votre
disposition pour vos questions en vous
remercions écoutez c'est nous qui vous
remercions parce que vraiment euh c'est
très intéressant et je pense qu'on n pas
souvent l'habitude de pouvoir avoir
voilà cette vision et cette comparaison
avec un certain nombre d'autres pays
donc c'était très très intéressant je
sais pas si mes collègues ont des
questions à vous poser je leur laisse la
parole Amel tu veux poser une question
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup en effet pour ces éléments
extrêmement
intéressants vous dites en tout cas vous
avez exposé des chiffres sur la dépenses
sur les dépenses en matière de logement
de la
France clairement vous soutenez que la
France dépense globalement un peu plus
que la moyenne des pays de l'OCDE est-ce
que dans vos évaluations parce que je me
doute bien que vous nous avez fait une
synthèse là ici de des chiffres que vous
avez pu que vous avez mais est-ce qu'il
y a des critères
d'efficience sur sur les politique
publique mené dans chaque pays est-ce
que cette ces éléments ont été été
évalué dans le cadre des de l'étude que
vous avez mené en 2019 ça c'est ma
première question autre
question un élément aussi intéressant
parce que vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que ici en France on évoque
régulièrement le sujet de la
décentralisation du logement euh
évidemment comme un moyen et
certainement pas comme un objectif
pourquoi parce que une meilleure
efficacité encore une fois no nos
politiques logement vous soutenez que le
pouvoir de décision fragmenté hein je
cite plus le pouvoir de décision est
fragmenté plus l'offre est rigide euh
est-ce que vous ce postulat est basé
essentiellement sur l'acte de bâtir ce
que j'ai cru comprendre dans dans ce que
vous avez évalué selon vous pourquoi
est-ce que vous disposez d'une analyse
plus fine sur ce sujet
euh et puis 3è 3è question euh
pareillement une de vos une de vos
expressions et de dire que la politique
qui vient à rendre les loyers plus
abordables et d'agir plus sur l'offre
que la demande est çaàd que les
dispositifs d'incitation fiscale
notamment pour les particuliers est donc
un un levier intéressant pour euh
disposer de logement davantage de
logement sur le parc locatif privé je
vous
remercie B
je vous remercie madame la sénatrice
pour
ces questions alors
oui peut-être manière liminaire oui nous
n'avons pas mené récemment d'études
spécifiques sur la la France il y a une
étude à profondi de l' CDE sur
l'ensemble du marché du logement
français en 2011 donc c'est un peu
ancien désormais en particulier pour les
dispositifs de
type incidation fiscale parce que bon
c'est dispositif très évolutifs qui ont
été beaucoup beaucoup cours Mané depuis
donc je répondrai sur à l'appui de ce
qu'on peut observer ailleurs de ce qu'on
a pu des travaux qu'on a pu mener sur
d'autres pays ou sur l'ensemble des pays
et ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut en en
tirer sur la France pour l'efficience
oui des dépenses publ
dans ce
domaine bon si on veut regarder si on
veut aller regarder à un niveau fin
dispositif par
dispositif bon ça il il faut vraiment
examiner le dispositif luimême on peut
pas va rentrer là-dessus en revanche ce
qu'on sait d'une
façon
générale c'est que
les les aides qui sont données pour ou
solvabiliser les locataires ou pour
solvabiliser les emprunteurs
immobiliers B souvent mobilise des fonds
importants et on a vraiment un effet sur
les prix c'est logique bon isant la la
demande et là on est on a pu et ça quand
je dis on a pu l'observer c'est c'est
pas seulement sur des exemples
particuliers de pays mais c'est aussi
quand quantitativement on compare ce qui
se passe entre différents pays on voit
que dans les pays
où l'offre est rigide où il y a peu de
construction on a vraiment des effets
sur les prix qui sont forts donc on
considère que quand on a ce dans cette
approche un peu euh un peu à vol
d'oiseau a priori on court le risque
d'avoir des politiques inefficientes
quand on s'appuie beaucoup sur ce type
de dispositif alors que lorsque on
dépense pour construire des logements
directement ou en finançant des des
sociétés qui construisent des des qui
construisent des
logements on on a beaucoup moins
d'effets sur les prix parce que oui on
agit sur l'offre et on a souvent aussi
des meilleurs résultats lorsqu'on
regarde les indicateurs sociaux en
France en particulier c'est intéressant
de voir que on a une augmentation
tendantielle des des prix d'immobiliers
qui a été vraiment très élevé c'est ce
qu'on voyait sur un des premiers
graphique mais on n pas eu finalement la
France est dans la moyenne pour ce qui
est de la du surpeuplement des des
ménages et en particulier des ménages
modestes donc ça
c'est on peut le il faudrait il faudrait
regarder plus précisément
pour établir un véritable diagnostic
mais euh on peut raisonnablement
considérer que c'est lié à l'effort
particulier qui a été fait en France
pour la fourniture de logements sociaux
donc sur la sur la décentralisation oui
euh en
réalité effectivement le
terme les oui le terme le le je je
parlais de oui de forte décentralisation
c'est plutôt la fragmentation qui est le
le bon terme parce que il s'agit pas de
dire oui que le marché immobilier va
mieux fonctionner si c'est l'échelon
centrale qui va décider le l'échelon qui
fonctionne le mieux c'est l'échelon de
la
métropole et donc c'est une opposition
entre la une décision qui est prise par
l'autorité métropolitaine ou une
décision qui va être prise par une
petite
municipalité comme ça va être le cas en
France ou qui va être prise parfois par
des districts comme ça va être le cas
dans beaucoup de villes américaines
celles qui rencontent des problèmes de
d'offre de logement souvent c'est lié au
fait que l'essentiel du pouvoir local
est un niveau sous
infraamunicipal
qui qui de fait
donne un une possibilité
au propriétaires qui sont en place de
bloquer la densification c'est vraiment
ça le le mécanisme qui est au cœur de
cela d'ailleurs au-delà du de la
difficulté que ça pose pour la réponse
de l'offre de logement à la demande
d'ailleurs quand on le regarde
quantitativement ce qu'on regardait
c'est pas la quantité de construction
c'est la manière dont la construction
répond aux variation d'offrees
c'estàdire que les endroits où on a peu
de construction mais il y avait peu de
de demande ces endroitslà voilà on les
en fait ils sont on les sort de
l'analyse c'est pas des des endroits où
on va dire que le euh que le système
foncier est mal organisé et d'ailleurs
on a un autre oui c'est ça on a une
autre difficulté avec cette
fragmentation c'est qu'elle a souvent
notre effet qui est de favoriser
l'étalement urbain parce que finalement
le seul euh endroit
où le mécanisme de de de décision locale
va être favorable à la construction
c'est la zone périurbaine où on va où
les il y a pas le blocage de la valeur
foncière déjà installée au contraire le
nouveau développement va
être bien vu et donc on a
une tendance à l'étalement ça on
l'observe notamment on l' beaucoup obser
on a beaucoup observé ce type de
phénomène dans des villes américaines
des villes
australiennes en Nouvelle-Zélande à
Auckland par exemple où on avait ce ce
ce type de de mécanismees d'étalement
urbain à l'œuvre dans des zones où le
la possibilité de densification est
extrêmement contrainte dans
les les zones métropolitaines
elles-mêmes enfin dans les cœurs des des
villes
elles-mêmes le
oui la question des loyers plus
abordables on
a peu
d'exemples
d'un alors je voudrais pas donner de de
réponse négative trop générale parce que
mais on voudrait dire ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il y a des on a des exemples
bon je parlais du de de l'Autriche du
Danemark de système qui fonctionnent
bien lorsque je on a un environnement
favorable pour les fournisseurs de
logement
abordable on a peu
d'exemples c'est plus difficile de
trouver des exemples de systèmes
d'incitation fiscale vraiment individuel
destiné au particuliers pour que les
particuliers fournissent des logements
abordables c'est sans doute plus
difficile à mettre en œuvre comme
dispositif
un risque qui peut se se présenter dans
ce ce type de dispositif si on a par
exemple une incitation fiscale
qui va être disponible à condition que
infin le logement locatif n'excède pas
un certain loyer un petit peu par
construction on va financer la
construction dans des zones où la
demande est relativement modérée des
puisque ce sont dans ces zoneslà que les
loyers se trouveront à des niveau
compatible avec le dispositif et on va
être assez impuissant avec ce type de
dispositif à traiter le problème de la
chireté des loyers dans les zones où ils
sont déjà
élevés donc on a donc c'est compliqué
de d'avoir ce ce type de dispositif
alors que lorsque on
a des des acteurs comme ces sociétés à
but non
lucratif autrichiennes c'est coopérative
danoise qui
on ont une possibilité d'accès au
foncier complètement différente d'un
particulier qui peuvent construire des
des immeubles enfin c'est le leur métier
de de de faire ça
ell voilà sont dans une bien mieux placé
pour aller répondre à ce à ce type de
demande dans les zones tendues qu'un
dispositif qui va s'appuyer sur les les
investisseurs
individuel alors la manière la manière
dont elle fonctionne
c'est elle donc elles ont accès à un
fond centralisé et elles-mêmes doivent
reverser
une partie de leur profit à ce fond pour
construire et ce sont
des entreprises à AB non lucratif qui
vraiment voilà construisent des
logements le loyer et règlementer sur la
base des coûts de construction plus une
part de marge et la part de marge sert
justement à F ce fond centralisé qui va
servir ensuite pour le financement de
nouvelles construction et aussi pour le
financement des rénovation lourde
oui après ce qui
voilà oui je voulais vous remercier pour
votre exposé aussi très intéressant et
j'avais question j'étais hier dans une
réunion avec des pays de de l'Union
européenne sur la question des
politiques urbaines et ils ont souligné
globalement la malgré la crise l'Union
européenne avait la crise qui depuis un
moment sur la construction de logement
avait limité le le limité la baisse de
construction de logement qui avait quand
même eu des investissements encore sur
les logements donc je voulais savoir si
vous faisiez les mêmes les mêmes
constats sur l'OC de nous en France on
est on est un petit peu on a des
chiffres qui montrent que c'est pas tout
à fait ça donc voilà on était et puis
j'avais une question sur l'offre et la
demande aussi encore euh voilà comment
on a vraiment une une inadéquation en
France entre le la demande de logement
que ça soit sur du locatif ou sur de
demande de d'accession à la propriété et
puis sur sur l'offre qui est qui est
proposée pas forcément parce queque
parce que ça correspondent pas toujours
au besoins aux localisations et aux
besoins euh des des gens moi je des
personnes vous l'avez dit c'est les
logements en vacan sont peut-être pas
toujours dans les endroits où les
personnes en ont besoin les logements
abordables sont pas toujours dans les où
sont pas toujours d'une qualité qui
permettent enfin qui qui conviennent au
au à la demande donc comment euh dites
que c'est que c'est plus efficace de
jouer sur l'offre que sur la demande
mais voilà on se trouve là face à une
conjoncture comment font les les autres
pays est-ce que cette inéguation aussi
entre l'offre et la demande est aussi
dans les autres pays de de
l'OCD merci beaucoup de votre question
pour répondre oui à la dernière question
c'est ces difficultés sont vraiment très
largement partagées et ce phénomène de
raréfaction de l'offre
et très est présent on
a on a vraiment beaucoup de beaucoup
d'exemples pour
le pour ce qui est de l'évolution de la
construction d'une façon générale dans
l'OCDE on a eu un fort assement de la
construction avec la
l'enchaînement d'abord de la flambée des
prix des matériaux de construction on a
aussi eu une augmentation des coupts de
main d'œuvre dans la construction le la
la hausse bon même si la hausse des prix
de l'énergie bon qui même s'ils ont
fléchi reste nettement plus élevé que ce
qu'ils étaient auparavant l'énergie bon
est importante pour la la construction
donc avec tous ces facteurs là on a
vraiment eu un ou repli généralisé donc
je sais mais est-ce que CIT le cas avant
aussi est-ce que c'est vraiment depuis
la
crise on on on a quand même un dis qu'on
a on a les on a les deux d'une faation
on avait cette ce niveau insuffisant de
de construction euh qui
explique pourquoi on a cette hausse
tendantielle des prix du logement qui
ont tendance à aller plus vite que que
que l'inflation et ça décennies après
décennies et à à cela c'est'est ajouté
ou les difficultés qui sont venues après
la covid donc on euh on se retrouve
aujourd'hui oui dans dans une situation
et quand je dis on oui c'est vraiment la
plupart des pays de l'OCDE dans une
situation plus compliquée parce que on a
un peu plus de demande parce que
beaucoup de ménages veulent un peu plus
d'espace on avait le problème d'offre
préexistante qui est amplifié par le
tassement de l'offre de le tassement de
la construction
pendant la
crise la crise de la covid
et donc il y a
vraiment un fort intérêt à trouver les
moyens de permettre la construction et
notamment en
oui libérant la possibilité de
construire alors c'est
euh ça veut
dire le fait
d'avoir la possibilité de monter en
hauteur dans les zones où c'était où
c'était limité de faciliter les
reconversions aussi he il y a vraiment
beaucoup
de de difficultés dans beaucoup de pays
alors je crois pas que ce soit le cas en
France mais il y a des pays avec qui ont
encore des systèmes de zonage qui
empêchent de reconvertir des des
quartiers désignés comme commerciaux
ou ou de bureau en logement mais souvent
on a des problèmes plus difficiles de
normes de construction qui font que il
est extrêmement difficile de reconvertir
des bureaux en logement au-delà du coût
technique de du coût technique de le
faire donc on a vraiment besoin de ce
travail là et ça me paraît spécialement
important dans avec l'optique notamment
en France du Zéro artificialisation net
qui lorsqu'on le combine à au manque de
logement dans notamment les zones où
l'activité économique et dynamique ça
rend vraiment important le fait
de
libérer la possibilité de mieux utiliser
les espaces qui sont déjà artificialisés
je je souhaiterais pour terminer vous
poser une question sur le Mall logement
euh est-ce que c'est des un sujet que
vous avez regardé à l' de l' CDE parce
que bon dans notre pays on voit bien
qu'il y a de plus en plus de de
personnes qui sont soit mal logées soit
pas logé du tout avec les conséquen que
cela peut entraîner est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous avez regardé et
sur lesqueles on peut avoir des des des
des données qui soit sont comparables au
contraire avec des des solutions qui ont
été apportées sur sur ce point-là plus
particulièrement alors c'est je je vous
remercie madame la président de cette
question je c'est une question qui me
donne envie de fixer un
rendez-vous parce que euh les données
existantes de malogement qu'on a elles
sont assez parcellaires la meilleure les
deux meilleurs en fait qu'on est c'est
celle que j'ai montré sur le
surpeuplement et la pauvreté
énergétique il y en a une autre dont on
dispose mais qui aujourd'hui est un peu
dépassé mais pour de bonnes raisons
c'est par exemple on peut comparer assez
facilement entre les pays le pourcentage
de logement qui n'ont pas d'accès à une
salle de bain ou à des toilettes
internes mais ça fort heureusement ces
logements sont en proportionilà très
faible dans les pays surtout dans dans
les pays de l'OCDE qui ont un niveau de
de de vie comparable à la France donc de
ce fait pas un indicateur très
intéressant il y en a un sur lequel
j'aimerais pouvoir vous répondre mais je
pas vraiment mesure le faire pour
l'instant mais nous y travaillant c'est
le sansabrisme
euh mais alors aujourd'hui on a des
indicateurs mais qui sont pas
comparables entre les pays parce que
certains pays comptent vraiment les
personnes qui dorment
dehors certains comptent les personnes
qui donnent dehors plus les personnes
qui sont dans des abris temporaire et
sans avoir le partage entre les deux
d'autres inclus aussi dans le
sensabrisme les personnes forcées de
loger chez des amis ou dans de la
famille ou chez de la famille sans que
ce soit véritable logement pour eux et
mais justement nous sommes en train de
un travail pour rassembler sur au moins
certaines de ces définitions des données
comparables pour bon qu'on est un nombre
suffisant de pays pour que ça ça aille
du sens parce qu'on a des des situations
vraiment très très différentes en
matière de de traitement du du
sansabrisme mais on a des
euh des des pays notamment c'est un des
domaines où on a des des succès par
exemple en Finlande finlandais ont
construit des logements spécialement
pour les sansabris et ont obtenu voilà
beaucoup de résultats
merci Amel ben écoutez monsieur je pense
que voilà on a été vraiment très très
intéressé et on vous remercie de de tous
ces éléments que vous avez porter à
votre à notre connaissance je suis sûr
que ça présentera un réel intérêt dans
le cadre de nos travaux merci beaucoup
et on vous souhaite une bonne fin de
journée je vous remercie beaucoup et je
suis à votre disposition celle de vos
collègues pour toute question
complémenta mais je pense que en tout
cas notre administrateur Mathieu ne
manquera pas de revenir vers vous si
besoin et en tout cas cet échange a été
extrêmement intéressant sur des points
qu'on évoque très peu mais qui sont au
combien édifiants merci merci à vous
merci beaucoup à
vous